nous avons pris livraison maintenant de huit Aston
Martin, celles-ci sont sur mesure, elles ont
été spécialement construites pour ce film,
nous avons des héros Aston Martin qui sont
juste immaculés pour montrer leur beauté, nous avons des
cascades Aston Martin qui sont entièrement en
cage de cascade  les ont
mis à l'épreuve adorent
l'idée que cette voiture fantastique soit dans
une sorte de bataille en tête-à-tête avec une autre
voiture incroyable de Jackie O qui est tout
aussi extraordinaire en fait, c'est donc
un jeu de chat et de souris dans les
rues nocturnes de Rome  à grande vitesse
entre deux les voitures les plus rapides du
monde ni une sorcière que vous n'avez jamais vue
avant ce soir, nous avons complètement
fermé les rues de Rome et nous avons terminé
une scène où vous êtes le film mr.
Hincks poursuit son ennemi diabolique James
Bond,
nous avons l'Aston qui est évidemment
une voiture rapide et lisse au design classique, puis
nous avons des indices qui est une bête d'un
personnage dans la bête d'une voiture qui est
la Jaguar CX 75
c'est incroyable c'est pour ces scènes c'est
va être très emblématique que juste avec
les deux voitures qui courent dans les rues
sont bien et souvent faciles et c'est l'une de
ces choses que vous voyez toujours dans un
film de James Bond
vous